imagining that there was some an
inappropriate behavior onset between you
two you seem highly unprofessional both
Brian Brian went on a commando - oh well
yes yeah but when I go nobody wants to
see I was actually there's a scene where
I'm on the toilet yes taking care of
business and he has a paperless
household so there's there's a machine
that words and spritz water and it's
malfunctioning yes so keegan-michael key
who plays his right-hand man had to come
in and manually repair
well no not manually but you know what I
mean
yes yeah the repair yes and it was we we
had one take of that that was 46 minutes
long because I could not stop laughing
in the scene - he's so funny he gets
right down right he's looking at you
while you're on the toilet there's
something very funny about when someone
invades that space yeah yeah yeah not in
real life
but I don't realize I wasn't laughing
you